y abrió una cuenta de ahorros el año
pasado y puso una cantidad inicial en
ella
sea mdt el saldo de la cuenta medido en
pesos
te días desde que fue abierta que
significa la proposición m de 30 - m de
0 igual a 100 antes de responder vamos a
analizar m de 30 cuando te vale 30 o
usamos 30 como entrada en m a ver déjame
ponerlo aquí te iguala 30 y esto lo
usamos como entrada en la función m
y obtenemos de salida
m de 30
y lo que nos está diciendo es el saldo a
los 30 días a ver vamos a notarlo este
de aquí
es el saldo
después
de 30 días
y utilizando ese mismo razonamiento m de
0 es el saldo a los 0 días cuando
abrimos la cuenta así que vamos a
escribirlo este de aquí es el saldo
inicial
y lo que nos están diciendo aquí es que
30 días después de haber abierto la
cuenta tenemos 100 pesos más aquí lo que
nos están diciendo es que la diferencia
entre el saldo después de 30 días menos
el saldo inicial es igual a 100 pesos
otra forma de pensarlo es que tenemos
100 pesos más 30 días después de haber
abierto la cuenta y ahora es momento de
ver las respuestas la primera dice que
30 días después de abrir la cuenta el
saldo de la cuenta de argel era igual a
100 pesos esta respuesta de aquí dice
que el saldo a los 30 días es igual a
100 pesos pero lo que nos están diciendo
aquí arriba es que la diferencia del
saldo a los 30 días menos el saldo
inicial es igual a 100 pesos así que
esta respuesta que está aquí no es
correcta
podemos olvidarla ahora vamos con la
segunda dice ar
tenía la cantidad inicial de dinero en
su cuenta 30 días después de abrirla a
ver vamos a volver a leerla y vamos a
indicar dice ar contenía la cantidad
inicial de dinero la cantidad inicial de
dinero la cantidad inicial el saldo
inicial es m
de c
y después 30 días después esto que está
aquí es m de 30 y lo que nos dice esta
respuesta es que la cantidad inicial de
dinero y 30 días después es la misma que
contenía la cantidad inicial de dinero
30 días después de abrirla para ser
consistentes con esto que dice aquí la
ecuación sería que m de 0 es igual a m
de 30
y esto no es lo que nos están diciendo
en esta proposición así que esta tampoco
la vamos a tomar en cuenta y finalmente
arjun obtuvo una ganancia de 100 pesos
en los primeros 30 días desde que fue
abierta la cuenta y esto tiene sentido
porque lo que nos están diciendo en la
proposición es que la diferencia del
saldo inicial si se lo restamos al saldo
de los 30 días esa diferencia es de 100
pesos se obtuvo una ganancia de 100
pesos así que esta es la respuesta
correcta